okay let's move on to the to the real
story of the day because this is
absolutely extraordinary and and it's
also
um i'm feeling very proud of america
right now because the people that we're
about to show you these are pro-american
people you're going to see american
flags
and people chanting about freedom and
you know why they're doing that
because cuba has a communist regime okay
and these people want to be free right
they don't want to be under
the gun of the government all the time
actually this past weekend
i was in miami and miami obviously has a
tremendous amount of
cuban refugees cuban immigrants and
ironically yesterday i took a very early
flight it was sunday morning i took a
very early
flight from miami back here to la and
i'm in the uber
and the uber drivers most of the uber i
can't say most but a huge percentage it
seems like most of the uber drivers in
miami
are cuban now that might be for good
reason they come to this country to find
freedom and then they have to work
jobs not everyone wants to be an uber
driver but it's a great job to have
so that you can hopefully build a better
life for your family and your children
all that stuff
anyway i'm talking to the uber driver at
like seven in the morning before these
protests were happening as far as i knew
and i don't think
i don't think they had even started yet
and he was going on and on about how
much he loves america and how much he
supported trump
and how he hates biden and a whole bunch
of other stuff anyway then i get off the
plane and then i'm seeing all these
videos
of what's going on in cuba so first
we're going to show you a quick
compilation about 40 seconds of three
different videos
about what's happening in cuba right
this very moment
[Applause]
[Applause]
okay so there's obviously many many more
videos like that there's tons of videos
with
american flags and people chanting free
they want freedom they want
liberty all of those things it will not
surprise you that so far the message out
of our administration joe biden tweeted
something and then saki said something
that basically these protests are
because of covet lockdowns and
and not being able to get enough
vaccines yes i am not making that up
that's what biden's
tweet basically said it is complete
nonsense that is not why these people
are out on the street
that might be five percent of it that
they're not happy with whatever the
communist regime is doing related to
lockdowns and vaccines and everything
else
these are people who want to be free you
know that thing that most likely if
you're watching this show that you have
that they don't have in places like cuba
and places like venezuela in places
like north korea that's the thing that
they want the thing that we so
take for granted so of course our
administration is giving a very
confusing and muddled message
because the the administration in effect
because
clearly biden whoever is running the
dividend show
saki all of the democrats at this point
because they
obviously have leanings that are in kind
with the socialists with the communists
they like that stuff that's the stuff
they're ushering in here
they don't want to come out as
anti-communists right so the messaging
is very confusing
these aren't pro-capitalists or
pro-america or pro-freedom
uh rallies these are actually rallies
because of kovid vaccines like it's such
extraordinary nonsense absolutely
extraordinary
uh so we've got a couple tweets here we
picked three people
they happen to all be florida people
because there are so many cuban
immigrants in florida so i thought this
would be interesting so first this is
from senator marco rubio
who is his family is from cuba he often
tells the story
of his parents as first generation
immigrants protests in cuba isn't simply
about shortages
socialism promises guaranteed food
medicine and income if you give up your
freedom
when as always it fails to deliver you
don't get your freedom back
that's why protesters are chanting
libertad
and then he has the couple hashtags
there that people are using on twitter
then from governor
of florida ron desantis florida supports
the people of cuba as they take to the
streets against the tyrannical regime in
havana
the cuban dictatorship has repressed the
people of cuba for decades
and is now trying to silence those who
have the courage to speak out
against its disastrous policies
and then finally this is miami mayor
francis suarez who you may
remember i interviewed a few weeks ago
in miami his father
was the mayor of miami and now he's the
mayor of miami his father
from cuba i believe francis was you know
francis was
was born in miami for sure he said the
cuban regime's military police are
shooting at unarmed cuban protesters
fighting for freedom
60 years of communism cruelty and
oppression
cannot last any longer we are imploring
the usa
to take action as we peacefully
demonstrate on the streets of miami
so that's some of the messages all three
of them obviously are republicans
from california as i said uh because of
the location
of south florida to cuba there are
tremendous amount of cubans
in in miami and in florida more broadly
and if you just want to meet a group of
people who love freedom who love america
and all of those things then you should
meet some cuban americans because
they're a great example of what the
american dream absolutely is
now i will read some tweets about what's
happening in cuba
from aoc ilhan omar and bernie sanders
oh wait there are none
there are zero tweets from aoc ilhan
omar
and bernie sanders and a bunch of the
other ones from the hamas caucus
and the point is and the reason is that
there are no tweets from them
as i said is because they actually
support the regime
they want the united states to be
more of a communist socialist
dictatorship they want
the government to have all of the power
so they don't want to
promote anything that might show people
yearning for freedom
and yelling about liberty and showing
the american flag because it's the
antithesis
of everything they believe so really
think about what's going on right now
like again you know as i always talk
about we all have friends that are on
the fence about these things a little
bit
unclear about what you know the truth is
what the what the real message of what's
happening of the in the day is and it's
like this is a pretty great example
those people want freedom who's standing
up for the freedom well i just mentioned
the florida senator
marco rubio the florida governor ron
desantis and the miami mayor francis
suarez
one of them or two of them happened to
be cuban originally you know
so it's like you see you see what's
happening here and then nothing
nothing from aoc ohan and bernie sort of
like the first story
meditate on that i will